[Music]
there's a lot of sports that people
watch because you know they want to look
for fights and one of the you know
hockey for example is a great sports or
people like I hope they get into a fist
fight you know what I mean
um I never wish that I would never wish
it on people I want everybody to get
along and just play a good clean game
well then you're not going to like this
you're not going to like the state of
[ __ ] stock car racing then could you
imagine being in a hockey game in a
great fight breaks out and somebody goes
you know this is bad sportsmanship come
on guys this this guy's stuff just ruins
the game why can't we just get a good
clean hockey game going boys [ __ ]
you know that they put people on teams
specifically to fight right yeah there's
always every team has one guy who's okay
at hockey [ __ ] knock people out with
one left hook the black guy
the black hockey player
um
look at this
you know if you're inside that top ten
we got trouble we got a major fight
going on down here
and I mean Timbers have Flair kicking
the race car we got fists flying we got
all kinds of stuff going on Andrew Grady
trying to go after the driver of the 41.
getting some trouble for this ain't he
yeah you're punching a guy by the way if
you know if you've ever been inside of a
stock or a NASCAR it sucks if you're the
guy in that car because you're stupid
and it's tight you can't move and you're
in this harness so you're in a torture
harness while somebody's punching you
you're in that Dale Earnhardt device
yeah exactly a coffin
yeah the device kind of came out after
I at least in hinted after him we saw
him show some displeasure on the
racetrack
a man you get you get these dumbasses
that come in here and run with us and
they have no business running a late
model much less a lawn mower I mean he
he wasn't close he's really mad man
he hooked me he erect Brandon Pierce in
the process I don't know what any of
these words mean and I wanted to
so I started oh hold on a second though
if he flipped him off also this is a guy
who's been in a fight and had his
earring ripped out
oh yes Mike Tyson in his head I mean
you're in a big
I started Mike tysoning his head is what
he just said it's like a grown man ass
Whip and that's how I mean honestly if
more of this happened I could watch a
NASCAR this is awesome I mean that's how
I feel this is the other guy but he said
that you flipped him off no I never
flipped anybody off uh he just come
started punching me inside the race car
so I
I understand he's frustrated but again
it was for the transfer spot and we were
just fighting for our life so
wow can I say this guy is totally
political wow this way better than the
other guy right look I understand it's a
hard game
that's the smart play because then when
you're both sitting in front of the
[ __ ] all of them go later or whatever
yeah you can be like hey look man things
happen I know tempers flared man I I
didn't throw any punches and yeah I'd
like to move on the this the true Chad
move is for him to show up and go I
don't even think he should be suspended
yeah exactly you know what I forgive him
as long as you apologize you know what
yeah if he if he's like look we re we
really he apologizes oh that hurt that
would be my move
I don't want him to miss any work man
that would be [ __ ] up we all got
families to feed here such an [ __ ]
I'm so mad I'm mad because if I was the
other guy I'd be looking at you like you
son of a [ __ ] oh yeah you son of a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] if it's the
fly between late model stock car drivers
at Martinsville Race I started on like
one of these like when the boss isn't
looking you go you do a little kiss Adam
and he's just in the chair just White
Knuckles like you [ __ ]
Tyson in his head
The Late Model stock car series is
sanctioned by NASCAR roots
two late model stock car drivers got
into an altercation on a Saturday
afternoon after a crash during the
qualifying races at Martinsville to be
fair two fight two drivers didn't get
into a fight One driver as we pointed
out was strapped into a [ __ ] harness
that basically the same harness they use
on a space shuttle and then [ __ ] and
you're stuck in a roll cage and some guy
was just throwing punches all blindly
into the roll cage you're right and um
the only feeling the other reason I was
thinking this guy probably isn't as mad
as he could be is because he was
probably wearing a helmet so the guy was
probably punching his helmet you know
what I mean so because the fact that he
ran like three other drivers off the
road so he probably just won by default
yeah good point yeah